so in our previous video on how memory
worked we got to the point from storing
one bit of information that we could set
or reset it to the flip-flop where we
could store a bit of information and
then we arranged for them together in
parallel so we could store four bits of
information so what we did we had four
inputs D naught 2 D 3 which gave us our
input and four outputs Q naught to Q 3
which gave us output and we connected
for each of the flip-flops the clock
input together so that when we strobe
this input it stored all the information
on the data inputs and presented it out
at the output this are still only
allowed us to store one piece of
information it was a bigger piece we can
store here a number between naught and
15 or fuse 2's complement between minus
8 and 7 but it was still only one piece
of information so we're gonna look at
now is how we can arrange flip-flops so
we can store more than one piece of
information so actually if you're
implementing a membership like this one
which is a 8k by 8 bit memory chip you
wouldn't use flip-flops as we've seen in
before you'd actually arrange about 6
transistors to store each bit just so
that you can fit more on to the actual
silicon if you put flip-flops as we
design them on they take up more space
also we're not going to consider like
this is an 8 bit wide bit of memory or a
byte wide memory will still consider one
bit so we're only going to store one bit
of information we're going to store
multiple different bits if you did want
to store eight bits of information you
could just have eight chips one for each
bit that you wanted to store so I'm just
going to use the flip-flop symbol that
we had before to represent it so we've
got a data input which we'll call D
we've got an output Q we've also got the
inverted Q output and we have our clock
input as well that we can use to tell it
to store it so whatever is on the input
is stored in the flip problem goes to
the output when we take this low and
then take it high again or vice versa
depending on how it's actually built now
we want to store more than one bit of
information so what I'm going to do is
then in store two bits of information so
I have another flip-flop exactly the
same so now we have two bits of
information now several things we need
to do we want to have
one input to our system so we have one
date a bit that we're going to store and
we won't be able to choose whether this
story in this flip-flop or in that
flip-flop well the first thing we need
is some way of saying which flip-flops
value were actually interested in
storing the CPU refers to every single
memory location by a unique identifier
but rather than having a name like any
programming language the computer uses a
binary number to refer to each memory
location this is what we would call the
address so in this case I am going to
say this is it address 0 and this one is
at address 1 so now I want to be able to
access either this one or this one
well first thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to have a data input which I'm
going to call D in here and that's what
we're gonna put our signal now if you
think about how flip-flop works they
only change the value they store when we
strobe the clock input so actually we
can connect to the input directly to the
input of the first flip-flop and we can
also connect it directly to the input of
the second flip-flop like so so how do
we choose which one we want to do in
what we could have in this case to
strobe lines and just strobe the right
one well that would work fine for two
bits and it wouldn't be too bad if we
had four flip-flops but if you think
about if you've got 64 kilobits of
memory that's 65536 different wires and
so it gets unmanageable when you get to
high numbers so what we do is we say
well actually we're gonna have an input
which will call a in the address input
and if this is zero then we're going to
refer to this one and if this contains
one we're going to refer to this one
we'll also have a signal W which we'll
use to say we want to write whatever bit
is in D in to whichever flip-flop is
specified by a in so all we want to do
is to be able to strobe the input to the
zero flip-flops clapping when a in
contains zero and W is strobe or strobe
the input on one flip-flop when a in
contains one and W is stro so we need to
connect via digital logic again
these inputs to the clock input of that
from zero or the pop input of flip-flop
1 and to do that we use our old friend
the and gate again gonna start with
flip-flop 1 because it's the simpler one
to think about how we do this we want
this clock input to be strobed where W
is strobed
and a in contains a 1 and so the easiest
way to do that remember our and gates
and you can look back at some of the
videos on numberphile if you forgot all
about them this is a and gate so if we
put a NAND gate in here we draw that
like so now if we think about a NAND
gate again it's got two inputs a and B
and an output which again will use Q so
if we look here we see that whenever a
is 1 the output matches B so when a is 1
and B 0 the output is 0 when a is 1 and
B is 1 the output is 1 so we can use
this fact these values here in our
circuit here we want clock to be
whatever the value of W is which we've
connected to input be on the and gate
whenever the input a n is 1 so we can
just connect that line directly in like
that and so now whenever we strobe W the
clock input on flip that one will only
be strobe if a in contains 1 or the
address 1 now how do we do the same for
0 we want the same thing to happen so I
could bring my wires down here so what
we need to do now is work out what are
going to be the right inputs for a and B
on this and gate now the input for B is
easy because it's exactly the same as
this one here the W signal the right
signal to say we want to write it we
just bring this down and connect it up
but we need this thing to be 1 whenever
a in is 0 so the way we do that again
remembering your digital logic is that
we use a simple not gate like this which
just inverts it so when the input to the
knock cage is 0 the output is 1 when the
input is not gate is 1 the output is 0
so we can connect this
in like so and so now what we've got
said oh is that we've got three inputs W
it says when we want to write something
to our flip-flops DM which contains the
value we want to write and a in which
tells us whether you want to write to a
flip-flop zero or flip-flop one
depending on the value of zero one in a
in we either store the value and that
one always store it in that one and of
course you can expand this up to cough
let you draw it but if you wanted to
store say four you'd have to a inputs so
you have a zero which would contain bit
zero of your binary input and you'd have
a one which would contain bit one and
course remember your binary inputs would
then be a 1 and a 0 and so you'd be able
to refer to 0 0 it should give you
location 0 again 0 1 which keep address
1 1 0 should give you a dress 2 and 1 1
which would give you a dress 3 and all
we need to do is build up a more
complicated circuit which combined a 0
and a 1 or not a 0 or not a 1 with the W
signal to connect to each of these
flip-flops so that's how we would do the
writing to 1 we can choose whichever
flip-flop we want by the address and
then we can strobe the W thing to write
it to that one or that one
what about reading how do we combine the
two outputs from our flip-flops into a
single output arm system in the first
Archimedes would run reliably well above
100 degrees C this is just the half
adder we want a binary full